- I think the most challenging
thing about the project
was really telling
Harry Burn's story right
because when you're dealing
with a historical subject
they really deserve for you
to tell their story correctly.
And, Harry T. Burn's story
really stood out to me
because it showed the
power of a single vote
to really effect a great deal of change.
He wasn't sure how he was going to vote
and he received a letter
from his mom, Febb Burn,
telling him that he
should vote for suffrage
and be a good boy.
And, it was really important to influence
Harry Burn's decision because
he was trying to decide
whether he should go against
his constituents and party leaders.
And, getting that letter from his mom,
who was college education
and civic-minded,
who really deserved the vote a lot more
than many of the men who
actually had it in Tennessee,
that really reminded Harry T. Burn
of the importance and the rightness
of the cause of women's suffrage.
That really was, I think, decisive
in making him choose the right
and ratify the amendment.
- When I learned that it was really
a combination of both historical research,
political courage, and writing,
that's a confluence of things
that Jeffrey absolutely loves and adores,
and I knew he would really like to do it.
- I think political courage is timeless
and it's needed even more today
because we're increasingly
polarized and politicized
as a society and government.
Courage is a choice.
It's not so much just a
character trait you have.
It's really a choice you make in a moment
to do the right thing, even when people
are pressuring you to do the wrong thing.